yes oh no this is a lot harder than it
looks
i made a mistake that was a big fail
[Music]
i just don't want you to fall
[Music]
hi i'm hannah i'm the world's okaiest
mom and we are
obsessed with tick-tock we should all be
asleep right now
but we're up watching tick-tocks per
usual
so we're going to try something for a
full week
we're going to make a tock every day
we're going to do seven different
challenges in seven
days do you think we can do it yeah i
think yeah
wish us luck i decided to do this tick
tock challenge because
to be quite honest right now i'm hardly
engaging my kids
at all i'm working from home i have a
four month old
and two older kids and literally the
majority of the day
they're doing whatever they want they're
sitting in front of a screen
whatever works right now and i'm doing
basically the bare minimum as a parent
so first challenge was a drawing
challenge
my kids and i actually saw this
challenge a couple times
and it was so funny we really couldn't
stop laughing at it so we had to try it
hey guys there is an art challenge where
you have to draw yourself
using the whirlpool filter on so i'm
going to try my best
oh no okay it's fine these lips are
flawless i'm coming for your career
kylie
and then we're going to look at it
without the filter here we go
oh my god it looks just like me
we're going to try this tick tock i
can't dog i'm so tired
so what are we going to draw this pizza
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay
drawing a pizza it's very hard to
film yourself making a tick tock that's
so good
i realized if we were having so much
difficulty on this challenge
i was in for a rude awakening the rest
of the week hello
we're gonna try a food
challenge what have we seen all over tik
tok
that like instant coffee
the whipped coffee right yeah and so
what are we gonna try it with wyatt
chocolate chips no matcha
okay but we gotta film the tick tock
ready there you go
hold it straight again very difficult
to do stuff and film tick-tock at the
same time
jackson no you you hold it wyatt jackson
can you hit the record button
yes oh no what
oh no we did a 15 second by accident
shoot so all of a sudden i had like
.5 seconds to show the finished product
so it's like a nice lengthy step-by-step
and then just like
boom finished product done oh gosh this
is the worst tick tock of all time
that is really yummy
that's actually really good okay
this is worth the effort this is so good
my tick tock on the other hand
not so good i'm tired these are a lot of
work
well we have one plan today that's
really really funny what do i need to do
go get your hoodie
get some socks and get your pants ready
go
okay i found this tick tock that
literally i still to this day can not
stop laughing over
there close the laptop
time to wake up
[Music]
again
[Music]
a new chapter
makes it look so easy to do this stuff
but we ran into so many hurdles
okay i'm gonna have to clip this in the
back this is a lot harder than it looks
this is the part that i don't know what
to do with your giant
head oh my gosh wait hold still hold
still
jackson you look amazing how are you
feeling
sweaty
[Music]
if i had to give it a grade i'd give it
a b minus it made me realize
very quickly that the people who make
these really creative
innovative really detailed tick tocks
are spending a lot of time on it
that was a big fail okay i'm counting on
you henry
you gotta be really safe for our next
tick tock it was
baby henry's time to shine
i realized very quickly that henry is
much younger than the baby who was in
the
original tick tock we saw how did they
do it did they do it on the shoulders or
on top of the
no it needs to go over me we're so close
so we picked a black maxi dress and
wyatt volunteered to film it
and it was just a disaster
oh my goodness getting really hard
jackson show him how he didn't know when
to push start and stop he didn't know
how to record
the dress just didn't look very good so
we did a part two
okay ready
[Music]
let's go let me get him out
my dance moves are not the greatest in
my defense i was more focused on holding
henry
and not dropping him or doing anything
wrong
than what i was doing with my legs so i
watched it back and was like
well i did that i have another idea for
another tick tock
it's a challenge that i've seen people
do a lot of times with a green screen
i don't know how to do it i don't know
how it's done but we're to give it a try
wyatt i think you are the perfect
volunteer for this one
we're going to do it with this giraffe
whoops
you're not actually going to sit on it
we realized that the back of our couch
is the perfect place to pretend
like why it was sitting on something
with the green screen so we were just
trying to find something
that we could photograph that it could
look like he was sitting on
so we found henry's brand new giraffe
toy
and used that as the green screen this
is gonna be good
okay
that's perfect why look at this
that is so funny no that's that wait
this is a success
this tick tock was the best performing
tick tock of the week
i think it was really creative and
simple
and just really fun and light-hearted
and everybody loves wyatt
so it performed really well so this next
tick tock
is a couple's challenge so
i'm gonna need to pour myself a glass of
wine i'm probably gonna need to pour
matt a glass of wine to convince him to
try to do this with me
i brought you a glass of wine
you're so cool
oh that's good you're so fun and
hit oh yeah you're just buttering me up
for a tick-tock i need you to do a
tick-tock couples challenge with me
i go like this you put your legs
put your legs down i mean your arms down
on the ground
and then you lift your legs up lift your
legs up
and then lift your arms up and then i'm
supposed to lift my
arms up what i can't no way
back even out the weight a little
okay
no there's no way that's what it is
let's consult the video one more time
see
you're gonna drop me on my bike okay
fill me
[Laughter]
[Music]
to say that it went badly is an
understatement
we tried so hard i honestly to this day
don't understand how the tick tock works
i'm too
old for tick-tock i ended up kind of
having a little meltdown about being too
old for tick-tock
so wyatt volunteered to film the tick
tock and i didn't realize that he was
recording
my meltdown about being too old for tick
tock
and that was the tick tock so the end
result is a giant fail
oh man not my best moment
this was supposed to be something fun
for us to do as a family
and it ended up starting to stress me
out for no reason i'm
in the bathroom i need to take a shower
but here's like a very
candid look at
my life um i just
i've been getting a lot of messages from
people asking like
how i'm god
how i'm keeping it all together i'm like
i'm trying really hard
and i'm reminding myself every day that
i'm so lucky
i'm so lucky right now
but it's not easy all i see on the
internet are like
homeschool ideas for parents and fun
activities to do with your kids
and all these different things that
you're supposed to be doing to engage
your kids and there just aren't enough
hours in the day for me to do it
the whole point of this is if anyone out
there
is feeling badly
about not doing enough just know that
nobody's keeping it together right now
it's really hard it's okay for you to
have a breakdown like me right now
because
this is hard
so i saw these tick tocks that have had
they do like a
themed dinner and i think that would be
really fun for us to do a themed
[Music]
dinner
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i thought it'd be funny to do a
different type of theme of dinner
because we just happen to have a lot of
the stuff in our house
what does it say oh you'll see goth
dinner
okay we're dressed it's makeup time
you look so good look at me oh yeah
look at me
i'm not as good as i used to be at this
are you ready i'm ready
[Music]
okay are we ready
[Applause]
you know
[Applause]
matt always surprises me he all of a
sudden had like a full interpretive
dance that he wanted to do for the tick
tock
[Applause]
[Music]
this was the most fun tick tock it was
the most time consuming tick tock but
also the most fun and we ended up eating
dinner at like
9 30 p.m but it was worth it
so having done a week's worth of tick
tocks i have some thoughts
it's less fun if you put pressure on
yourself to do it
the way that tick tocks are successful
is if they're very real
and natural and just
in the moment we had a good time but
for future tick tocks i will stick to
what i know which is just
filming funny things that happen in the
moment nothing fancy
so that's all i got for today i'm hannah
and if you try any of these tick tocks
let me know message me on instagram or
tag me
because i want to see that i'm not the
only one having a hard time with these
now if you'll please excuse me i need to
go work out because
matt and i at some point need to be able
to do
a couple's challenge till next time
[Music]
you